all set
okay good morning
uh this morning is a work session
on our four
remaining bills
and the idea is to go through them find
out
are we ready to exact on any of them
and if not
why
and what are we going to do about it
the other thing i want to announce right
away is that
we have five new bills that came in as
second committee bills
i'm scheduling these for next thursday
four of them in the morning
and the marijuana bill
scheduling at one o'clock
in the afternoon
so we can go as long as we need to on
the marijuana bill
on all five of these bills
the policy has been determined
we are only going to deal with the
revenue part of these bills anything
that has to do with revenues or
funds special funds
keep reminding yourself of that
we can't change the policy
we may not like it we may like it
but
our job is to look at the revenue part
of the bill
and that'll be for next thursday
commerce and finance okay
you know
and i've talked to the speaker
and i'm having
two members from commerce committee
uh possibly john hunt and somebody else
to come in
with the questioning
on the public hearing part
of the marijuana bill
so because they talk about a
special new hampshire bank
that we need the expertise of that
committee to deal with that
and i've talked to karen umberger
um
to have two people from finance to come
in and sit on the public hearing
associated with the
finance the revenue part
of that bill
so that
they can help us with the questions and
the things that we need to
address
in order to know what to do
what action to take on the bill
so that will be just for those two bills
speaker has approved it
they will not be voting members
but there will be
members of the committee for that date
to ask questions
representative
thank you on
i'd like to congratulate you on putting
the
the uh
economic update session next friday
instead of this friday
an issue of hope that
they aren't going to do this to us again
we lucked out on that
representative yeah i think
the reason we're inviting finance is
that there's a 24 million dollar ask in
the bill
for funds to
see getting the stores open and all that
that's unbudgeted so
that's why finance is going to be
involved with the marijuana bill
and it's only going to go to one
committee
so we're at and then we're inviting
these others thank you
any other questions before we get
started
if not
then we have four bills to go through
this morning
we'll start off numerically
with house bill
on 1097
representative genevieve and
representative spillsbury we're going to
interface
with
the dre attorney and
also hopefully with sam garland from the
attorney general's office
but i think everybody received an email
from sam garland saying why he couldn't
be here today
and uh
that it's taking longer to come up with
with
language
to help us on this bill
uh representative spellsbury or
representative
[Music]
yes uh yeah thank you mr speaker so i
talked to uh
sam garland yesterday
and um
he
feels that this bill is very important
um and would like another seven to ten
days
which i know is gonna make it tight
um
and uh he
really would like um
to come with some language you know in
in the next seven to ten days so
i don't know if there's a way for us to
fit that in or not
if you would get back to him and say
he's got seven days okay that's it
we're out of time okay so we would need
it back by
when uh thursday of next week wednesday
there's a problem
is that
to
do it next week
it has to
be in the calendar
and the shut off for the date for the
calendar was yesterday right
so it
it's going to be stretched to the
beginning of the following week
so
and that's why
we won't have another chance at it
so
that brings up
so we would have to vote these final
four bills out then on the on possibly
the tuesday of that but that's but
wouldn't these bills have to be in the
calendar for the
for the uh
session
what is the session
so we gotta we gotta we got a math
problem here
is there any way we can um
we have to execute these four bills you
know
so hold on a second
we just pick up no no because the
calendars published on the thursday
before
out on friday
tuesday the 9th
for wednesday the 16th and thursday the
17th it's the 10th though he's moved the
session back another week without
changing the deadline formal deadline
but he's moved it
a week earlier without carries my
impression was the speaker was planning
to have sessions on two consecutive
weeks
yes he is
mr chairman
it is uh right now the calendar uh for
sessions is set at the 10th
the 17th possibly the 16th if there's
the number of bills that would take up
that much time and then again the 31st
so that's that's the session calendar
that we know about right now
the tenth
is the last time
we have to report the bill out
so we
we have one bite of the apple to be able
to do that
because the tenth is the following week
after next week
so
so it's alarm confuses we have a session
on the 10th
that doesn't mean that all the bills
that are not in second committee bills
in the calendar it says last day to
report house bills not in a second
committee which were these four bills
so we could still vote those out by the
10th
it may not be in the calendar for the
vote on the floor
because there's another date coming up
after that correct am i not missing
that's what i'm seeing here
right right
so okay so we're not as much problem as
i think
by the 10th you know then it'll be on
the calendar for the next right
session
and we don't have much
of an opportunity we have a couple days
it may be a monday or maybe a tuesday
but that's it
all right
okay
so then
that's it for today on 10
97. well mister you get a hold of yeah
well so i have a question are we going
to i mean i've got to give him a drop
dead date so should it be
tuesday the 8th i mean it depends when
we're meeting we'd have to meet um on
the 8th to the 9th
right
but
i would like to have his information
sent to the entire committee before we
meet
and we'd have to then make an amendment
as well
yeah
so probably by the eight i probably need
it by monday the seventh i would guess
okay
okay monday the seventh
it's still tight
representative
oh oh wait a minute
oh
kane
so maybe thursday the third
can you help us out
uh good morning i just wanted to add
another comment here um even though if
we give attorney garland a date by next
week
the dra would still need time to put in
our input and um
so i'm not sure if
and the date for next week is it closer
to the 10th so i just want to make sure
that
make sure the committee is aware of uh
that we need to put in our input as well
we haven't seen the language from from
the ag's office yet
so we may end up
putting this into internal study and the
real
income study bill
we may not have a choice
can you um get a hold of mr garland also
tell them
tell them our concerns here
so mr chairman when i talked to
attorney garland yesterday he said that
within that
seven to ten day time frame he was going
to
contact
uh keen and
and try to come up with some language i
know it's a tight time frame
so we're depending on you
to work that out for mr garland
um so so just to be clear
we want to be we want this bill to be in
session for the 10th
uh we have no choice but to vote on it
by the time voted on by the 10th yeah
by the ninth by the night
with
with full uh comments from the dra yes
does not feel
i want it made clear that if the dra
thinks that a part of
the draft the
amendment
would
work against our existing tax system
that
it has to stop
so made clear to to
attorney garland
he's yeah if i may he's aware of that
when i talked to him yesterday he was
very concerned about how dra felt about
it and wanted to make sure that any
language she proposed the dra was fully
um
accepting of okay so mr chair
representative ames
uh
i guess in light of this discussion and
also our previous discussions about this
bill about the issue that's trying to
address
it's complicated um that's why uh we're
not getting an immediate response from
the ag's office it's complicated
and it's
it's something that you want don't want
to
do quickly if you don't have to and so
and i don't really see an urgency to
this issue so that uh
when we get to it and we can go through
this process for sure
i certainly lean towards an interim
study
on a subject like this
under these circumstances
thank you
thank you representatives
any further comments
thank you mr chair
i'm actually quite surprised that
the ag's office and dra hasn't had this
in their radar and thought about this
already i mean you would think that
with this issue that they would have at
least given it some thought in the past
year or so
so i'm i'm kind of
surprised that they would need more time
to look at it
but that's just a comment thank you
thank you representative
any further cars i got a comment thank
you mr chair
is possibly i mean maybe the middle step
is if we run out of
runway
try to get by the date
um is there any way we might be able to
attack a bill that's been fully vetted
onto a senate bill that we may get
there's a possibility
maybe it could be possible but i
i think this is more of a standalone
bill
we'll deal with
what mr wang and mr garland comes up
with
representative tunisian and
representative spellsbury
if there's nothing else then we'll go on
to the next bill
um
i better go make
um i have to step out for a couple
minutes
so representative
romney will
open up the work session on house bill
1221.
okay uh
12 21 is uh has to do with the the rates
on the business profits tax and the
business enterprise tax
and i think um
i think
representative janae again
has in a moment
sorry
yes
the amendment is um
2022-0471
h which i passed out at our last work
session
hopefully everyone
has access to that but it's very simple
if you don't basically the amendment
removes the reduction to the bet
tax and so
reduction so basically we're only
looking at a reduction of the business
profits tax from 7.6 to 7.5 percent
and um
uh again according to the fiscal note
the lowering of the bet and that um
can i just ask if um i don't know if one
of the ques i think one of the things
from the last work session was that dra
would um would bring you know if only
the bpt is being lowered the fiscal
impact of that i think i think that's
what we had
all right we were we were going to get
some
just additional information yes
members of the committee i'm devin
roderick senior financial aides
department of revenue
we did respond to the um to the fiscal
note request for that
and the impact of only lowering the bpt
tax rate would result in that first
chart in our original fiscal note
it's a 1.8 million
dollar reduction in revenue in fiscal
year 23.
followed by a 7.2 million reduction
fiscal year 24
in the 8.4 million and 25 fiscal year
25.
so in the in the original fiscal note
there was a few charts in the very end
of that fiscal note
it would be the
it's the second chart
in that original fiscal note if you have
that
any
any questions on the
does everybody have that those original
charts representative gene again
yes um i i do have that chart um i think
the thought was and and maybe this isn't
true but i thought the thought was that
if the bet
when businesses
correct me if i'm wrong but when
businesses pay the bpt
it's with the reduction of the bet
against it therefore if there's no bp
bet reduction
would the bpt still be about the same or
i think that's why we thought there may
be different numbers
so we
in our original fiscal note i don't do
you said you have that i'm sure i refer
to the right so it's um bullet number
eight in section c
um speaks to that relationship between
um the bet credit available to offset
bpt
and
that
um
that analysis was is not included in
this fiscal note any sort of assumption
in that relationship
all right
represent
representative
yeah my follow-up just was just that i
mean right you were assuming that in
this chart that both of them were being
reduced
so now that the b e t is not being
reduced the bpt
the numbers here would still be the same
for bpt
for for our estimated fiscal analysis
based on a prior um prior fiscal year
revenue that would be the case so we
didn't
we didn't make this an assumption of
what taxpayers would use for that
that credit against their bpt
because it's it would seem to me that if
we're not lowering the bet by the
estimated
uh what was it
27.5 million that means that's an extra
27.5 million that the bpt
would be you know the tax would apply to
so therefore the loss in the bpt i would
think would be lower than the eight
point
uh
yeah the eight point four seven so maybe
it's around eight million
so would that be reasonable i don't yeah
i don't think it would i appreciate the
question i don't think it would be a
reasonable assumption to assume that all
bet paid
is used to offset bpt entirely
um some that that isn't the case for
some tax payers for many taxpayers
didn't analyze that
if keane wants to provide a comment
um just wanted to add to that comment
also
in our analysis we didn't take into
account that we
some taxpayers may only pay bet and some
taxpayers may only just pay bbt
and some have a combination of both bpt
and bet so in order uh so our analysis
is it more of a standalone
oh sorry our analysis is more of a
standalone analysis in terms of just the
bpt calculation and the bet calculation
without taking into consideration the
crossover
of application of uh bet over bpt
otherwise it's going to be a much more
complicated analysis
and i don't think we were able to to
manage that
and that's why the
uh the rate reduction of just the bpt is
still the same
same analysis the same value as as the
original calculation
okay thank you
representative uh elmy yes thank you it
may be a more complicated analysis but
it could be quite a bit of money
so
what would it take to do that
would you have to go and open up
people's folders in the basement as we
used to have to do or
um
because
that would probably mean
a detailed look into every taxpayer to
determine who is you which taxpayers
utilizing bet and bpt bet credits
against bpt
um
that that i think that's just
and the analysis is an individual
taxpayer analysis doesn't show
the analysis system isn't capable of
picking those out
at this point
um
we can definitely take a harder look at
that and get back to the committee
if you'd like
and try and make an assumption on the
usage of the vet
credits against bpt
could you do it before the eighth
yes
thank you
i mean the other way to look at this is
this 8.47 would be a worst case scenario
and that not lowering the bet most
likely is lowering this
to below 8 million would that be i mean
if that's a
a fair
um
guesstimate then then
maybe we don't need to put you through
more analysis unless you don't think
that's a
i mean how
how do you feel about that i think the
the effect of the bet credit with the
rate unchanged would be an
indeterminable
positive effect on this analysis
as you say
another important note to point out is
that this analysis is based on fiscal
year 21 revenues
we use that as a tax base to determine
the impact but i do agree with your
assumption
so i mean unless you think otherwise mr
chairman maybe we
we move forward with the assumption that
it's
less than this figure this is a worst
case scenario it's probably less than
eight million
um the difference
if that's what the committee wants
uh
it looks like we're not going to
get any
additional information that's going to
really sway us it's either going to be
8.4
7.8
or 8.5 this isn't going to make much of
a change
representative
albany are we sure it's less than 8
billion
why are we sure it's less than eight
million and which year are we talking
about
so our estimated fiscal analysis based
on fy 21 revenues
places the timing of the impact at 1.8
million in fiscal year 23
up to a full impact of 8. just under 8.5
and fiscally are 25.
based on the comments of representative
genegan it's
i believe it's a reasonable assumption
that if you do not decrease the bet rate
it would have a
an
indeterminable positive impact on that
estimated impact
as some taxpayers
which we have not analyzed can
use that bet paid as a credit against
their bpt
representative when we get to 24
we were looking at 23 million
if most of that
sorry when we get to 24 we were looking
at a 23 million dollar impact on the bpt
when we take the bet out of the equation
and if most of the taxpayers were paying
bet
we could have another 10 million that
year
that was lost in bpt it seems to me
it would be really nice to have
the analysis if the if the system will
do it
i realize that take going down to the
basement and looking at the files is not
on
we'll take a harder look at that
relationship in our analysis and we'll
get back to the committee
soon
and it won't be by the 8th it'll be
sooner than that
i understand and if we can't do it and
we pass this anyway we're going to need
it for
revenue estimating
further questions comments
represent representative
um is it appropriate to talk in general
about the bill at this point
go ahead yes um
i feel the the bet
is paid by our more uh
invested businesses in new hampshire
there's more of them it would have a
a better impact on those businesses than
the bpt
the money that they would save would be
in turn go back into the economy locally
and whereas the bpt savings would
not necessarily stay in new hampshire
and i think that should be a
consideration
as well as what representative major
said last time
when we were sitting here that
maybe we should let
the cuts we've made settle down before
we make more
so my feeling is we shouldn't make any
cuts at all but if we do
it should be the bet
thank you
thank you representative
representative
um yes i i would
i would count it out with the fact that
you know a cut to the be one of the
reasons we're not cutting the bet is
because
it is a much much bigger impact there
and because of that same reasoning we
want things to settle down
we are willing to leave that
off the table
and not cut any other taxes but the
focus would be just on this bpt tax uh
reduction from 7.6 to 7.5
i mean the
i did a little more digging to make sure
more accurate figures we compare
favorably with some other surrounding
states at 7.5 percent massachusetts
charges a flat 8 percent tax
on bpt so
while there's not a big difference
between 7.6 and 7.5
it's still more of a round number it's a
little bigger of a of a difference and
then maine
i'm sorry vermont uh charges anywhere
between six and eight and a half percent
the um but really the six percent is
only on the first ten thousand
um you're up to eight and a half percent
as soon as a business has more than 25
000 of taxable profits which is not a
very high figure so for the most part
vermont's at eight and a half percent
massachusetts is at eight percent um
and i know
i know some have been concerned that
we're giving
some big companies a tax break um that
in their opinion they don't need however
we've got a lot of large employers
in this
state um that that offer good jobs i
mean fidelity is one of them um good
high-paying professional jobs you have
many hospitals that are in the top 100
employers in the state and they um
employ many people
and they're also
um
they've got a lot of good jobs in in
those companies so i think you know
it's not it's not all bad if we're if
we're helping out
big businesses in this state
there's there's certainly an advance to
that and then of course the other side
is outsiders looking in saying
new hampshire's got a 7.5 percent
business profits tax i think it just has
a good look and i think
you know as we said earlier willing to
take other tax cuts off the table to let
things settle down but this is one i
think we need to let move forward
thank you
representative ames
yeah i spoke to this point uh
previously but i'm going to
underscore it again my town in jeffrey
is facing a three dollar
per thousand tax
increase rate increase
as a direct consequence of a
significant cut in state schooling
and there'll be a vote on that
within the next two weeks
that
increase will impact
the big companies and the small
companies
all the commercial enterprises that are
located in jaffrey along with of course
our residents and residents who pay
taxes
and i think we need to bear that in mind
there are two bills in the senate
that will provide additional school aid
for uh
towns like jeffrey and
and another one is rindge
the cooperative school district is
jeffrey renz as you may know
and uh that money is desperately needed
it may be provided but there'll be
always a question of whether there are
sufficient state funds to support it
and i don't want to
lose that
because we need to make this gesture
which is essentially what it is
uh
on the business profits tax side
uh so i just wanted to make that clear
thank you
further comments
just
so everybody
considers this
when you compare one state against the
other on their taxes
you have to look at all the taxes
and
new hampshire is doing pretty good on
the
business profits tax
were competitive now about the states if
it was just business profits tax
but it's not just business profits tax
all these businesses
have to
pay in maine
new hampshire a maine vermont
massachusetts
income tax
and a sales tax on their goods
which where in new hampshire we don't
have to pay any of those things
so
we need to consider these things
when we go forward
all right
anything else
so i'm not then
we look forward to your analysis
and i was
i made those comments not in favor or
against i just wanted to make sure
people understood
the next is house bill 1524
which is establishing a national service
alumni attraction and retention fund
and representative schoenberg
is not
is not able to make it here today
and so representative murphy
you're going to
yes thank you mr chairman um
representative schamberg is not here
today and so he asked me last week if i
might introduce his amendment to 15 24.
uh i did hand it out it is amendment
0722h
along with the 65 to 25 uh paper that
uh
illustrates the um the goal to have
about 65 percent of our young people or
our working force
with a degree greater than high school
by the year 25 which is endorsed by
their governor and
businesses throughout the state
representative schamberg
gave me some written testimony that he
would like me to read and i will
paraphrase some of it
i believe that this uh amendment uh
tries to address some of the
concerns or questions that were brought
up previously in in work sessions
uh you know as we know this um
bill is really an attempt to recruit and
retain really qualified caring community
service individuals to our state
it's basically to establish a fund
called the national service alumni
attraction and retention from fund
in the the treasury
that would allow volunteer new hampshire
which is actually one of 52 state
service commissions across the country
which makes grants to
colleges it would be our new hampshire
colleges and public private nonprofit
employers in the national service
network
as we know volunteer new hampshire is a
c 3 nonprofit organization
which is somewhat of in my mind what
sounds like a quasi governmental uh
institution as it's attached to the
department of administrative services
governed by a board who is appointed by
the governor in the executive council
um
so in the amendment
some of the
comments that
representative schamberg wanted to make
was that
section 4
roman numeral 1 line 7
this fund was hereby established in the
state treasury just to make sure that
everybody knows where this fund is
located
same section for roman numeral one line
nine
uh after the word assistance words
workforce development and education are
inserted
basically to establish the explicit you
know permissible uses of this fund
section four again roman numeral two
lines 19 to 21
allows the commissioner the department
of the administrative services to accept
and credit funds from various revenue
services sources
such as grants or donations stipulated
for the purpose of the fund
other sections like
section 4 roman numeral 3 lines
22 to 30
shows the parameters
of how these funds would be distributed
and importantly
section on page 2 section 5 line 11
the new word is
is is transferred versus
hereby appropriated which was
implied as a budget appropriation for
general funds
and that was really not the intent of
the original prime sponsor
all these funds are coming from
discretionary funds from the arpa fund
the american rescue plan act of 21
and still remains within the power of
the governor
this really is a three-year innocence
pilot program it is really intended to
try to recruit and retain
what i think we would all consider some
very valuable resources uh in
individuals who may contribute
substantially to our educational system
but also to our workforce
interestingly i was driving down this
morning and listening on the radio and i
forget which station i was on but our
neighboring state vermont
and i didn't real i realized this before
but i forgot is actually the number one
oldest state in the country i think
we're a number two or three and their
major issue right now is workforce
retention
and trying to keep some of the young
individuals of the state to stay in the
state
from personal experience i know from
where i live up in the upper valley
many people unless their
children are tied directly to a business
a family business
people leave in the state
and so what this is really an intent to
do is to recruit some of the best
qualified um you know value-oriented
community-oriented individuals to stay
in the state
personally when i was you know in
practice
one of the hardest things i think most
people here recognize as well recruiting
and retaining good people is very hard
to do
and it's very costly and if we have a
relatively cheap meaning no money is
expended by the state only through the
opera funds
we may be able to establish a program
whereby
going forward we can look to see what
happens in three years if in fact in
three years we see that there is a
sizable uptick in the number of people
that are recruited to go to college here
stay here or in the workforce stay here
i think then we can start looking at
alternative ways to fund this whether it
be grants or federal supportives of that
nature
but regardless this is a
basically a pilot program in a sense for
three years using the monies that are
allocated through arpa to try and
recruit and retain the best
it's hard to have people i know from
personally recruiting people at various
levels of training and in practice
it's hard to bring people to new
hampshire
they think that we border on canada and
we do
they are afraid of that they know we
have cold hard winters they are not
familiar with new hampshire but
personally having recruited a number of
people who are really qualified and
talented people when they come to the
state and they realize who lives here
who works here
they actually are the ones that want to
stay here
i would give you an example we have now
in the department of orthopedics at
dartmouth over 50 percent of the
candidates or the staff members there
are people that actually came from
elsewhere in the country but chose to
stay in new hampshire it's hard to
appreciate that you know looking at a
brochure of new hampshire with foliage
and beautiful pictures in the ocean
but unless they actually live here and
work here and get to know people it's
hard to recruit these people in the
state i think this gives us a great
opportunity
through a pilot program without any
financial burden on our taxpayers to see
if this can't be a tool that we can use
going forward to recruit and retain some
of the best
and so that's my personal you know aside
from what representative schamberg put
out there but i do think it's really an
important concept to consider
uh i i think that we are an aging
population in the state we need to
consider
some of the workforce
retention programs
that we have currently in place or don't
have in place and see if we can improve
upon those
to
improve our workforce situation uh
through this program so um
i probably went a little off script
um but i think it's a valuable program a
great concept
and i would hope that we could find a
way to
make this happen in our state
thank you representative
murphy representative
thank you
i just wanted to point out i just wanted
to point out that even
if um
this was
coming out of our budget it's
250 000
a year to be attracting and
and
getting to stay the very age group that
we
really
need to settle in new hampshire to keep
or keep settled in new hampshire
and
develop businesses
become
really strong employees of existing
businesses
and it's cheap
we're talking about 500
up up to 500 up to six thousand dollars
per student
and if there's someone here from
volunteer new hampshire i'd love to
see i'm sure they had something to do
with this language like to see on how
many people they think they might be
recruiting in a year
thank you
representative murphy thank you mr
chairman i just wanted to add that when
i was listening to the vermont uh
program
not only are they in trying to encourage
young people to stay in the state who
are leaving but they also are out of
their own coffers are actually
offering financial incentives to people
to stay in the state
further comments or questions
representative spillsbury
thank you mr chairman
um
thank you mr murphy for stepping in for
representative schamberg
i'm just trying to track exactly what is
being said in uh
new subdivision for roman numeral three
and roman numeral
four and make sure i understand the
mechanics so
basically each individual
would be eligible for
a grant ranging between five hundred
dollars and three thousand dollars
for a term
and
that that uh use of the word term i
think is saying a term of
national service
would that be a year what is what does
that mean a a term of national service
i can't i think it's a is it one year or
two-year representative on me but
i thought it was two years actually
peace corps is two-year commitment i
think of course i believe one year
that's correct peace corps is two years
and i believe the uh
uh national service is one one year yeah
i think that's correct
my quick initial read
i thought this was referring to a term
at school in any institution or
community college system but when i read
it more closely i
realized it it doesn't tie to terms of
study
it ties to terms of service already put
in
that's fairly ambiguous in terms of how
it would be applied
uh to the terms of study
and you know are we talking per semester
per year
multi-year i do see of course at the end
of the paragraph that it's
limited to an aggregate of six thousand
dollars which i assume
contemplates multiple semesters or years
of study
i would think that needs to be ironed
out
yeah i would agree and i but i i think
that it's important to know also that
this in my understanding is that this is
quote a matching grant so
each of the universities and or the
employers have to first come up with the
uh up to three thousand dollars and then
uh volunteer new hampshire will match
that um contribution that they've made
to their education or to their
forgiveness of debt okay so you've
anticipated if i can continue mr
chairman you've anticipated my second
question which was
what exactly is it that they're matching
and uh you've just stated it but i don't
think it's stated here in the language
um my understanding is that the universe
i'm sorry is it all right
go ahead
my understanding is that the university
um or the community college system
has to have joined
americorps schools of service
or the peace corps coverdale fellowships
if they are part of that organization
then they will then be able to
give a grant of up to three thousand
dollars matched by volunteer new
hampshire
for those that are in employ or going
into employment
the
employer has to be have joined the
employers of national service program
again another program that tries to tie
volunteers to employers and if they are
part of that program then they can then
offer a grant which is then um
or they can offer monies up to 3000
matched by a grant from volunteer new
hampshire but
it probably needs some tidying up on the
the language otherwise
yes i
i think that
who's matching what
is also not clear
and volunteer new hampshire shall
disperse the matching grant
so i think that's a new role for
volunteer new hampshire that we didn't
see in the prior amendment
and i'm wondering how that interjects
them
into a fund
controlled by the
treasurer
by the state treasury
i think the mechanics of those three
issues are all muddy
um
if i made one more sorry being very
technical here
uh
i was trying to discern the difference
between uh roman numeral three and roman
numeral four
and please help me if if i
don't have this right
first i thought it was redundant it was
an inadvertent inclusion twice but uh
maybe
maybe roman numeral four is trying to
get at something a little bit different
and that is if you're not going to be a
student and you're not looking for
financial aid prospectively
instead you would get a grant of the
same sort of figure
to apply against your debt service for
loans that you already are obligated to
is that correct yeah my
my understanding and again i didn't
write it and i'm not as familiar as
others may be with the program but my
understanding is that roman numeral 3
really is dealing with the
educational system meaning that if they
are students that come after service in
the peace corps or americorps
the university system may provide them
with some
grant money that is then matched by
volunteer new hampshire paragraph or
roman numeral 4 is specifically
virtually identical language in many
ways but it is dealing with the employer
who hires an employee to come to the
state
and then they will have their
debt on student loans reduced by the
same amount so the employer will give
them you know some sum of money up to 3
000 and it will be matched by volunteer
new hampshire so that's my understanding
of it
that that helps
but i i
i do think that this needs to be revised
again before we could possibly consider
would it be possible for you to send to
me your three bullet items at some point
and i will try to
see if we can get those uh answered for
you sure glad thank you
okay so representative spiltsbury will
work with representative murphy
to
get this ad
added to the amendment
further questions or comments
all right
then
we don't have much time
i'm sorry all right
now we're on the house
forward at the tom and see what happens
15.65
ah hold on one second
i'm sorry
once i get going and get passionate
about stuff
i'm trying to find it
oh there it is
okay 1565 relative to the
opioid abatement trust fund
and representative aaron has an
amendment
thank you mr chair
yes i'm presenting to the committee
today uh
an updated amendment uh
2022-0747-h
which i handed out to everyone also
handed out a spreadsheet to go along
with it
but
the only thing that's different in this
amendment
prior to the other amendment that i had
to this bill
and to the bill itself
is on line 14
that i changed the allocation factor
from 40 percent to 30 percent
and that was um in response to a good
call by uh representative allmey
with regard to the 40 percent factor if
you look on the spreadsheet on column i
what a 40
factor in the uh
calculation regarding uh the settlement
distributions and and this one on the
spreadsheet is just using mckinsey
as a
as an example
with a 40 percent factor it actually
splits the fund 53 percent and 47
percent
um
because of the uh
correction that i've made to the
population penalty
so if we
make this factor 30 instead it is then a
true
split of the fund of 40
to the um
political subdivisions that joined in
the lawsuit initially
and 60 percent would remain in the fund
so if we look at
column j
that shows
what the result of a 30 percent factor
would have been
versus what the actual
distribution of the settlement was in
column h
which goes with the
current 15 percent
allocation of the fund
and includes the population penalty to
the counties
so
um
so that's all this uh this amendment
will accomplish it also adds in
all the other
reporting changes and
includes
the
changes that are recommended by senator
rosenwald in her bill in her senate bill
so
that's what this
amendment does and i hope that it
will be acceptable to committee
and i believe that there are some folks
here
from counties and municipalities who
might want to speak to this change in
this
amendment
okay
questions mr can someone that uh address
the senate bill and then and where that
is
is that it bold
senate bill 275. can we just chat about
that a second sure
senate bill 275 is a bill that was
introduced into the senate
by senator rosenwald which makes
changes to the same statute that we are
looking at with this bill
and basically what she
is adding in is
a piece that
changes
the
county home nursing
county nursing home supervisor a
designee appointed by the governor and
the governor is stricken and adds in the
new hampshire association of counties
and then she also put in a piece
that adds in
um
another
task that the new hampshire opioid
abatement advisory commission should
perform
and that is to support evidence-based
or what they what they're tasked to do
is to support evidence-based prevention
programs and services
including efforts to promote healthy
drug-free lifestyles reduce isolation
build skills and confidence and
facilitate community-based prevention
efforts so they're just
adding in another
aspect of what the commission is trying
to accomplish one other piece of this
too
that she's added in
is in the first paragraph
that
on line 9
that the distribution of funds from
from the the
opioid trust fund shall be based on the
most recent decennial census population
in current statute
it only points to the um
the 2010 census so we're just making it
so that we don't have to keep changing
it every 10 years
i see these mostly as
um minor change manual tweaks
they're kind of housekeeping things
right and you've incorporated those into
this amendment as well and your big
change in here is 30 instead of 40 is
the allocation formula yeah
thank you okay senate bill
275 that's past the senate as amended
and
on senate bill 275
it specifies the 15 percent as
has been agreed in the past so it
doesn't change that so the senate has
already passed that
and what you're proposing
is to change it to 30 percent
right
and
well the senate i don't think um
were was considering uh
the the allocation factor and i it
wasn't written anything about the
allocation factor in there in the bill
there anyway
so
my point is this is that
all the things that you talked about
that the senate did
it's fine
but what they didn't do
is they did not change the percent
factor
they have base
to continue on
using that 15 factor
and then
also
beefing up the commission
that has to do with the allocation of
the 85 percent
adding
some additional
people
and
the nursing home administrator appointed
by the
the county rather than the governor
that so that the 85
is distributed as needed
with need
so
we do have a big difference here if your
amendment
it doesn't change that factor
right right well senator rosenwald's
bill didn't even
discuss
a change in the allocation factor not
because
they don't want it i think it's because
they just didn't think about doing it
i mean i have no idea i don't know
representing elmi
thank you
on the senate bill
was
amended in the
senate before they passed it
they discussed it they added in
some change
changes to
uh the commission
one of which you've captured which is
is appointing the county nursing home
supervisor by the association of
counties which is a very good idea
instead of the governor
and
the other of which is a
superintendent of schools appointed by
the new hampshire school administrators
association
and they made some changes to
accommodate that in the commission
and then they also
on
put in a specific
number 16 for
for the school problems
you know with opioids
and
they
put into the tasks of the commission on
that they should pay attention to
the available measures success and
corresponding data of the programs
so
it's going to be a moving target if
you're trying to create something that
would do everything they did except
change
change the numbers i think
you should probably just assume that
that if this passed the house that
there'd have to be a committee of
conference yeah
yeah but
i i was just anticipating some of the
changes that may have come from the
senate and incorporating it into this
piece of legislation
this proposal
i think though
that the crux of the matter too is
the allocation formula
and
you know whether it comes that comes
suggestion comes from the house or the
senate
i think it's just important for us to
consider
that um
the original 85 15
split
was
suggest was a suggestion from a judge in
ohio many a couple of years ago
and that over time you know we can take
a look and see
how the that um allocation
affects our
counties and uh and our uh
municipalities that originally joined
into this
um litigation
i think it's important to to bear in
mind that there are other states that
have also already
altered that original
um
85 15 split because they found it wasn't
really meeting their needs
and i think that when we look at the the
um
the 23 political subdivisions that
joined into this lawsuit and if it
wasn't for them
you know i don't know that we would be
even talking about having any money
in this fund to begin with
but be that as it may
i mean these 23 uh entities
represent a good 50
percent
of the opioid problems in the state
so it just seems to me to make more
sense that instead of them getting a 15
percent cut of whatever settlements are
coming that they should get a bigger
amount of that funding
to the tune of maybe 40 percent
with 60 percent which is a huge amount
of money still to be left in the fund
for other municipalities to to ask for
some grant money from
representatives
thank you i have been trying to get
data we have data
on
the
distribution of deaths which show that
they are
everywhere in new hampshire
we have uh
the
the largest problem is in manchester
that's quite obvious
and then nashua because of their
populations
and because they're
on the roots of the drug
drug
highways
i lived on the gainesville drug
highway many many years ago and it
suffered badly from
drugs because of that
but the fact is that they come into
places like unity and spread out across
all of the rural areas
around the upper valley
they come into
to
berlin and spread all over
on
there is no place that is exempt from
this
and
in general the research seems to show
that addiction
is more serious
in the rural areas that because the
people are isolated
because they don't have good access
to treatment programs that are in the
big cities
but
you're 13 which is what we're talking
about because the counties
represent the state
but the 13 that you're talking about
leave out
most of the
big towns
in new hampshire as well as
almost all of the rural areas
and
the commission seems to be very well
diversified
to
and has been working out priorities
and i wish that one of the people from
that
would come and talk to us here besides
attorney befetti who's mostly
talking just about the allocation but
not about what the commission is doing
thank you
well i no one i i i'm sorry okay anybody
else
represent ames
you want to turn your mic on
right
uh picking up on
representative omni's
referral to what the commission
uh
is set up to do
i've been looking at the criteria here
that are in the statute
that would be added to
with the two
additional paragraphs that have been
referenced by others
and it's
it's evident that much of the money that
goes to the commission
will flow through to
political subdivisions where there is a
need
and of course there'll be a great need
in manchester for example
um and much of the money will flow
through to manchester or more close
closer to my home
to cane
two political subdivisions that will
also be receiving a direct
amount of money through the 15 percent
as the statute is currently written for
example
uh these are the criteria that the
commission is to follow
and if this follows after a statement
funds may be awarded if the project
meets one of the following criteria
one is
reimburse the state
and and any political subdivision within
the state
for any portion of the cost of
administering
naloxone
well that's uh you know that's a
per
administration kind of
reimbursement program that's going to
flow to places where
the naloxone is being administered
and that's going to include
the big places that have
very intense involvement in this issue
and other places that have less intense
uh reimburse the state and any public
any and any political subdivision for
emergency response services related to
uh you know these issues
same thing it's going to flow through
to and within
these political subdivisions so
my point is that a lot of that 85
percent
is going to go to places that are also
receiving the 15
uh it's not 85 percent
here and then 15
there big difference
representative romney
thank you mr chair
what i'm struggling with is that this is
we passed this change it goes on forever
and obviously another legislature can
change
what the future looks like but
excuse me
but
these 13
towns
and cities
they're going to benefit from ever
representative ames is correct does
those represent me
first of all i don't have a problem with
the money going to the counties
forever i think because the word nimble
was used somewhere in one of the
hearings
and the counties are closer to the to
the action
and i could see i could make an argument
for more money going to the counties
and then having them work their programs
they know their county's the best
but
for all these towns to continue to get
going forward
i mean we talked about another
settlement just the other day 115
million
from the distributors like abbott and
all the others
and that's the tip of the iceberg
there'd be more settlements
um that we're gonna we're gonna lock
these these 13
communities in
for a long time now i know that's not
the bill we're not here to say
don't do it we're here to say do they
get 30 now not over 40 percent
uh i just i can't
i can't
i don't think that's right
i i would i would i would agree with
maybe more money going to the counties
going forward
let them work their programs i mean in
my little town at stratham i mean
greenland
we don't have we don't have
i'm sure there's drug problems
but we don't have facilities or we don't
have anything you know we're never going
to ask for that kind of money
uh because we'll be going to the the
the communities that are larger that
have those kind of kind of things
and it and it to me
our county rockingham
would be better equipped to accept money
that would
benefit
all of the community all the the other
subdivisions the community the towns et
cetera in the county
so
i don't know uh
i mean i mean i guess what's on the
table right now
is that we increase this to 30 percent
not 40 percent
and not touch any of the other and then
down the road i think we're going to
have to address
the 13 towns do they forever
i mean i i would agree that the county
should get
money and let them let them work that
part
but i don't think we have time to argue
now and try to change this
to amend out these towns that's another
discussion
but i'm i'm having problems
even you know look the agreement was 15
where i'm still right now is well let's
stay with the 15
and then we'll have the argument another
day about
um you know continuing to change this
formula but that that's that's what i'm
thinking right now thank you
okay anybody else know
that representative yeah mr chair thank
you i'm i'm wondering if there's anybody
here from any of the other
municipalities or counties that would
like to add in or any
of their observations or thoughts about
this
since this is a work session
if anybody has information they want to
provide
summarizing what they want to say
i can't hear you
administrators
okay
fine
if you would summarize
because
it's not a public hearing it's a work
session
yes sir uh kate horgan i'm the executive
director of the new hampshire
association of counties and with me is
county administrator chris cost from
cheshire county
county yes
thank you mr chair
um
i've been listening to discussion i
actually came to a previous one when uh
um manager uh uh perlin friendlin uh
spoke and
well i wanted to
let kate take care of her side of things
but i wanted from the county's
perspective from cheshire county
especially how we would look at this
money anytime we can have
funding come in
and take that layer out and we can
directly have
those monies come into the county we
don't look it as we do look internally
and i know that there's been talk about
m a t we we've had m18 in our budget for
years we were one of the first counties
to in in our county facility and our
in our corrections facility to have mat
in our facilities
medical assisted treatment
um
so suboxone whatever it may be
um that the individuals that are coming
in
and
when i looked at this money and
currently we have about six little over
sixteen thousand dollars coming in i
look at it the same way we looked at
when the cares money came out initially
it came through the state and we were
grateful to have any money come into us
but we advocated hard for when the if
there was going to be any more funding
american rescue plan funding
that we wanted to come directly to us
because we know our communities and when
county talks about community
it's not just about the counties not
just about the infrastructure we're
talking about the 22 towns in cheshire
county in the city of keene
so when we look at things we're looking
at as a whole
and and we've done so we believe we've
done some really creative things with
our american rescue plan monies we would
do the same thing here let's talk first
start with drug court drug court we have
a mid-size so we've received from the
state of new hampshire agreement before
you go on further
are you advocating going from the 15 to
the 30 percent or i'm always advocating
anytime that yes i appreciate the the
work that representative aaron has done
in this that if we could bump that up to
that would be great because we believe
we can utilize that money in many
different ways that you may not be aware
of okay thank you thank you mr chair and
you're representing another county so i
am the executive director of the new
hampshire association of counties and i
just wanted to make the committee aware
that all 10 counties are in full support
of this and many of the items that
administrator coats is speaking of other
counties want to do
things like building out the mat
programs so it's not just we're treating
them in the county jails and then
sending them out we could use this money
to partner with non-profits to continue
their treatment in the communities and
benefit
all the communities in each county
because the worst thing that can happen
is we're providing them with mat in the
jail
we send them out they relapse they're
back in the jail
within a year and then it's just an
endless cycle so if we could have that
handoff i think that opportunity would
be
great and the fact that we wouldn't have
if we had more funds and didn't have to
apply
to get those funds for a program that
may or may not get approved by the trust
we don't know the trust rules aren't set
up
if we got those monies now
and any future allocations that's money
out on the street faster i think is our
point so essentially what you're saying
the more money you can get directly that
you don't have to compete for the better
off you are correct we can we can we can
be as the word would say we can be
nimble with it we can get we can get
that funding out to those whether it's
reality check or whatever it may be and
then
those that aren't
from the county
but are
communities that
weren't part of the 13
for every dollar that's not available
for them to apply
it's going to hurt them
i would i would argue mr chair that the
counties cover the entire state so
regardless of whether or not a
municipality entered into the agreement
a community will benefit
thank you they currently are anything
else
representative
thank you
i am feeling very uh
disturbed that we cannot get someone
from the commission to talk to us about
what the commission itself has been
deciding
uh except
on the the side of the allocation of
funds
because what i get told by
the chair of the commission
who is senator rosenwald
she was appointed at the beginning and
reconfirmed by senator morse
on
is that
the first they've decided that the first
thing they're going to they need to fund
is the jails
on which would be extra money on top of
whatever the counties get
on
the the rules have not been approved yet
that is because of as i remember
blizzards
that happened when jail car tried to
meet
and they certainly will be approved
before this bill would pass the senate
and so this and the senate has direct
involvement with this commission
on
which we don't seem to have
and
i
i just do not understand why we can't
get someone else from the commission
to talk to us about
what they have already decided they are
planning on doing in
sending the money down because it
shouldn't take very long to send it down
once
all those rules are finished we do have
someone from colorado county i believe
we do
do are you spying to speak
i'm sorry are you speaking i hope too
yes so i i did want to say we did uh
plan on having attorney velardi who sits
on the uh opioid commission be here
today unfortunately he's in court um so
he does have a full-time job if you are
not planning on executing this bill
today
i can have someone here from the
commission
next week to talk to this group about
what they are doing but it is my
understanding that the commission has
not decided on how they are going to
spend those funds it is news to me that
the commission has agreed to fund the
mat services because i am
unclear that they can make that decision
before the rules are approved but
i will defer to senator rosenwald but my
understanding is none of those decisions
on how the money in the trust is going
to be spent has been made yet
okay i i will try to get in touch with
the commission and see if we can have
somebody here
next meeting
that's correct
representative romney
thank you both because you're my exhibit
a
um
i just as i was saying
it's it sounds like the counties are are
well equipped to act and understand
their their communities better than the
state does
and that i would have no problem
amending this bill to give more money to
the counties
but i have problem with
those initial towns
i mean i mean obviously
obviously the towns were within the
county so
it
forever and ever and this money's going
to get bigger and bigger that's coming i
mean these settlements are going to be
big
so i think i think
just in terms of nimbleness i think the
counties are are more nimble and they
understand their communities and would
do a pretty good job of allocating some
of this money not just to the jails but
to to other programs in their their
counties so
um i mean i've been thinking about this
i still have a problem with individual
towns getting this forever and ever
uh but you know
uh you know he actually kind of helped
me make my case here so thank you
okay um
we do have somebody
from is it berlin
if i could
is this
your name
and who you're representing thank you mr
chairman representatives my name is
peter morenci i'm with the city of
berlin
i am a
newly elected council person there give
you a quick background i've been
affected personally by by this
i'm a 35-year police veteran 20 years as
police chief
did 10 years on the new hampshire drug
task force
and my my own family was struck with
this
and
i found myself even with the amount of
time and the
people that i knew and the connections i
had
in the north country
we were
i was lost for resources
i couldn't when i get the call
that my daughter had been arrested
and needed help
i didn't have any place to bring her
there was there was no resources up
there
we've tried to grow that fortunately i
was able to get a hold of somebody in
manchester we talk about the big cities
we talk about the big towns
population based they are getting some
of the resources and i'm not here to
compete
but i'm here to tell you that three
thousand dollars
in in a lawsuit that we filed is not
enough for me
to provide my community with services
we look at things that we need
because i know that was one of the
things that was asked
we need an earlier childhood education
we need
family services
when when we looked at
where do we go
what do we do with our grandchildren how
do we take custody of those kids
how do we deal with their anger and
their frustration moving forward
there's a whole family makeup here
that's not being addressed and that
would
is just superficially being touched
i can only speak for the north country
at this point
but i do think that
we don't have a loud enough voice and we
need those resources
we need that percentage increased
i thank you for your time
thank you
representative
on i forget whether berlin is one of the
towns it is
so you're advocating for berlin
and then
the county
would share
its increase over the entire county
but whitefield and
and on
such places would not
see this the increase that berlin would
get it would be concentrated in berlin
i'm sorry i didn't catch up the formula
the way the way it works right now
uh the way that is being proposed
is that the county would get an increase
uh based on its population
and that berlin
by itself in cost would get
an increase
to spend in berlin
we're about the third of the population
uh there would be
yes but the other two-thirds would
on if they want
money would have to compete by
themselves
maybe with berlin berlin would help them
compete
that's that's correct
what we've had to do in the north
country is consolidate a lot of our
resources and work together um whether
that be
drug unit or support services and those
sort of things so we have worked
with the county
uh to to that point that we need to work
together we're all we have
yes but uh
there are also a lot of places in i
understand in coasts that are a long
distance from berlin so
thank you
further questions
then we thank you for your
comments representative herschel
thank you mr chairman this is more
that's okay uh this is more of a comment
um
i gotta see how i gotta get to this um
when
when the
when the towns are increased that are on
the list
along with the counties that are
increased on the list
towns are sometimes dependent on
counties for assistance does this
lessen the assistance that they would
ask for the counties to help them with
or would the counties not be able to use
this money at all to help those cities
that are in the litigation
the way it works
is that
as it is right now 85 15
goes directly to these
13 communities in the counties
they can
do what they want with the money as long
as it
has to do with
opioids
the 85 percent
will be distributed by this special
commission their recommendation
depending upon
their need
and how how it benefits
yes
thank you mr chairman as a follow-up to
that
i i've read through i read through the
legislation earlier and i've i've looked
at the at the um a mammoth that's come
through and i think that i'm st i'm
still missing and maybe i might have
missed a hearing or something so forgive
me of my ignorance um
i i'm still trying to find out or to try
to understand
why there has to i know that the judge
is the one who interpreted the 15 over
the case over the cases right the judge
said well we're just going to put 15 on
there
that leaves 85 percent to be requested
we know that there's a there's a payout
that's in here from mcken from from
mckenzie already in that settlement
but why do we feel the need of having to
hold back 85 percent
that's what i'm trying to figure out why
is there a need to hold back 85 percent
and make people beg for help
that's my question
that question if i understood it
why not give these 13 communities in the
county 100 insane
no i'm i'm saying that i think it's
reasonable to take it up to 30 percent
i'm i'm saying that so much is left over
for people to put in a request for that
they need help
but if if we gave more money to the
counties out of the fund still having 60
percent of the of the of the amount in
the fund
uh
to the counties and and even to the
cities that are on the list
what if if that fund is is already set
up for them
then why are we making them beg for it
why can't we just increase a bit more of
of the of the amount to go to them so
they can establish the programs they
need to establish or work on the issues
they need to work on
why does it why does it have to be 85
percent i wasn't part of that 85 percent
but i do know that
new hampshire is made up of 230
something
communities
most of the communities don't have the
resources
to even
know what's going on or participating
in these
lawsuits
and i also know that just about every
community there is in new hampshire has
a drug problem
every community that we have in new
hampshire
has to send their
emergency crews out
because of this
so they have they have expenses as well
as these 13 communities
the more that
we
give to
the
litigants
the less there is for all those
communities that didn't have the
resources
or the people in place
to join this lawsuit
so i i have no idea why they did a 15 85
split
but i do worry about those
communities
that
are small
still have to operate ambulances they'll
have to operate
emergency people and all that
is that
how do
we address them
and they're being addressed
by this commission
the commission's supposed to look at the
needs
of
where these funds are
to go
this is just the tip of the iceberg
because there's more funds coming
and a lot more fun to come in
settlements
that's my
comments now we have a gentleman in the
back that
thank you for your testimony
thank you
he's been waving his hand
and then representative murphy again
chris coates county administrator
cheshire county
and to your question if i may mr chair
i was part of the early negotiations
with actually
attorney general mcdonald at the time
and
a deputy attorney bonfetti
commissioner mcglarish
from stratford county
and
at the time the 15 percent we were
flying blind
we didn't know
you know so we too we there was we were
talking about buckets and we said
there's three buckets there's a state
this is trust and then there's the
subdivisions
and so we went with this number we
looked for guidance knowing that that
may change down the road because we
didn't know there wasn't enough
information to move forward to make an
educated decision at the time so that's
why we agreed to the 15 at the time is
because
we just didn't know where this could
land and we
dealing with it day in and day out and
seeing our community struggle with the
issues that they were struggling with we
wanted something
so i have 16 000 right now set aside for
that something but it could if it was
more maybe we could do more
thank you thank you
representative murphy thank you mr
chairman um
a comment and then a question and i
think it is somewhat related to what we
just heard
is that rather than
considering
fifteen percent thirty percent forty
percent
in knowing that your recent comment said
we're flying blind
it strikes me that from a clinical
perspective the idea is to put your
resources to where they are needed most
not based on an arbitrary you know grab
a number out of the air percentage but
specifically where the needs are most so
my question is then
how do we if 30 percent of the the the
need is in those
13 or 23 whatever the number is counties
and municipalities then that's where
they should go
if it's only 15 then that's where the 15
should go maybe it should be 0
and the entire hundred percent is
therefore applied for through a
non-onerous process to get the monies
they need to take care of their
population
so
my question i guess is is there a way
that we can get a handle on that and is
it unreasonable to consider
not a percentage number of 15 30 or even
you know
quite drastically even zero percent and
say it's all up for grabs based on need
based on
a non-onerous
method by which we can allocate the
funds so
to me you put the resources where they
are needed most not based on this
artificial number that is picked out of
the air but really based on real data
real understanding real need thank you
thank you representative murphy
representative tucker
i i had sort of a different thought uh
and that is i wonder whether we
shouldn't build into the legislation
that there needs to be a look back
period of time after five years
that the commission and others will meet
and see whether there needs to be a
reallocation just build in two or three
sentences that call for
uh
a look back
fairly early on 18 years is a long long
time
try to imagine
what the problems might be
in this whole area
we don't seem to be beating the drug
problems
and
it's very hard i think to determine need
i sent out
something to all committee members that
talked about unh extension
working with elderly people around the
state
who are addicted to drugs who had been
originally
prescribed drugs and we know this money
comes
from ill from prescriptions that were
not necessary
overblown
by medical personnel
and so that's a group that we should be
interested in
former police chief morenzie talks about
child care we have incredible numbers of
needs
but i think if we could put in a
five-year look back
it would give us a chance not to feel
that we're
making a forever decision
about allocation for 18 years i i do
think that's unreasonable
if we're slightly wrong
for the first five years on percentages
maybe that isn't the very worst thing
maybe we want to get that money out
as best we can with the knowledge we now
have
and then look back after five years and
see how it's working
thank you representative tucker um
rsa 126
either 83 4 5 or 6
kind of talks about that it tells that
the commission has to every year in
november put out a report
on
what happened
in the whole bet
and
i
think
we need to be able to look at those
things
i would ex
expect that the full committee
look at these rsas 126 83 84 85 and 86
and that tells how the commission was
formed
what their duties are
the members on the commission
and what their
besides the duties uh
reporting and that
and so that we're better educated on
what's going on
because if we just look at this bill we
have no idea
what's been put in
what's happened and why it was created
it was effective in
july 1
of 2020
so
it's new
and
because of the old point opioid
yes
so that's a wonderful idea so it's in
that section that perhaps we should say
the commission in the year
2028 must
read all its reports and
see whether the allocations are suitable
some simple sentence like that
with whatever year people think is
reasonable i think would give an
opportunity to re-juggle
based on experience
just reporting
we have a lot of reports and i read the
state parks report every year and i
imagine i'm one of 10 people other than
state employees who do
so reporting is
not useful to me unless it also gives
a chance to make a change because of
what the report is saying
okay
representative romney
yeah i just want to ask the general
cheshire
from jessar county
a question
so you you were involved in the
beginning of this
correct it sounds like the word went out
did the word go out to all obviously all
the counties
but did the word go out to all the
various municipalities if they wanted to
join
in the lawsuit that would that's my
understanding yes right
i i i don't know i can only
focus on the counties but that's what i
was told at the time and that's why
other towns
or cities stepped up and joined at that
point right okay
if anybody in the committee knows the
answer
that would be helpful okay
uh very thank you thank you sir
yes representative abrami
all the uh municipalities and counties
were
told about
this
upcoming
litigation
and were given i believe 15 months
to join in on it
and that was a
testimony by mr furland
from sullivan county
and these
23 entities the 10 counties and 13
municipalities
felt that
they had no idea what
they might gain from this
but they felt that if they could gain
even something
that they were going to join in and
and see what they can accomplish with
this which is why
they thought it was important to become
part of this litigation process
and and
in taking a look at this with the 13
municipalities and the 10 counties
we have seen data that shows again that
50 of the problem
laid in these areas
and so um
but that but that's what it was they
they were informed that there was this
litigation and a chance
for them to be able to get some sort of
uh
money from it
and then it's
they told it was any and all lawsuits
down the road forever
it seems like mckenzie was it mckenzie
or is it mckenzie just happened to be
the first case mackenzie was the first
settlement and they knew that there
would be more settlements down the road
yes
thank you
representative
thank you mr chairman
i haven't determined personally how i'm
going to come down on this when we vote
because i think there's
a tension between strong arguments on
both sides
i think in an ideal world representative
murphy put it well
you want to have a deliberative process
where
resources can be matched most
effectively with needs
and that i'm sure without having read
these provisions is exactly
why the commission
has been given this task
in the long term
they're far more equipped to make
judicious decisions than we are as a
committee of the legislature
but on the other side of the coin i
think what's motivating the bill
and i suspect without which we wouldn't
have the bill
is anxiousness
the bureaucracy moves slowly
and unfortunately if we were in a
situation where the commission had
already established its rules
and broadcast what criteria they were
going to use
then i don't think that there would be a
cry from the counties
for a
um
a short path directed amount of money
now i can see the mckenzie funds are
sitting there
they're anxious to get their hands on
some and they'd like to have more than
as indicated by the 15 percent but with
a long view to what happens over the
course of 18 years and multiple
settlements which are going to be much
larger
i think representative abrami is right
on and
i'm not really sure we're going to
accomplish something that we'd be proud
of several years down the road
representation
thank you um
i'd agree with that i
am much more sympathetic to the counties
in this
because they do
cover the entire state and hopefully
would represent their different towns
appropriately
but
on
i think that we have to be really
careful what we decide now
because if we increase
what what we increase
especially for the
municipalities is going to be very
difficult
if it seemed necessary and appropriate
to decrease because the largest cities
and the most
the heaviest voting blocks in
in the state
would be
pulling to keep what they had
yes i just have a question um
does the percentage
is it required by the settlement that
the percentage apply to all these
subdivisions
is it possible that for example just
give an example 30 apply to the counties
and and 15 apply to the subdivisions or
can it not be split out does it have to
be the same
across all
do you
i would defer that question to
miss oregon
north carolina is giving 60 percent to
their counties
straight off the bat and holding back
so i mean
i you know honestly speaking i haven't
spent a whole lot of time in this the
sponsors
have looked at this but what i'm hearing
with there seems to be a lot of angst
with
these
the city subdivisions
getting an increase
along with the county the goal being the
county gets increased a town like
salem that's not on this list that i
represent
i'm not sure if it
you know salem is part of rockingham
county so the rockingham so rockingham
county getting an increase to 30 percent
helped sell them but
salem not being on this list of
cities
would
i mean now that i'm
i mean i i understood the and kind of
agreed with the 30 now i'm starting to
think should it be split into counties
getting more
and these political subdivisions of
cities getting less
i'm just throwing that out there i'm not
necessarily making a statement that
that's what it should be
represented ames
just uh to pick up on the
question that was sort of proposal made
by representative tucker and her
exchange with you the chair
you you pointed out the legislation
requires
a report by the commissioner and just to
be specific that report
must it's a shall submit
an annual report which would include any
recommendations for future legislation
so it's a specific
order to
recommend the future legislation if
the
commissioner of the department of health
and human services sees the need for
that
thank you
[Music]
thank you mr chairman um uh for this
report that's being discussed right now
has it has this report been generated at
all by the commission yet and is it late
if they've been in if they've been in uh
if the commission was formed and uh back
from did you say july of 20
right well we're already in 2022. and if
it's an annual report then they're
behind
and i would like to see the report
good point
the lady if you were to identify
yourself and who you represent
good morning my name is catherine heck i
represent the new hampshire municipal
association and i was not planning on
speaking today but in light of other
testimony i thought it might be
important
i had just seen the amendment and i did
want to add that of course our towns and
municipalities do partner closely with
our counties on many many topics so i
certainly i'm only here talking about
municipalities and to your point 13
municipalities did step forward and
joined the lawsuit early on
and well they were informed as you know
different municipalities have different
of different sizes have different
capacity to take on topics like this
whether or not it's affecting their
community is a little different but
going into a lawsuit certainly is a
large undertaking for a
for any community and i do appreciate
those that were forward thinking and
decided to get involved in the lawsuit
but we have many other communities that
are certainly affected all of our
communities as we know in new hampshire
are affected by this
crisis
so this is very complex legislation um
we are following what other states are
doing to try because they're all in the
same boat of trying to figure out the
best way to allocate these resources
especially given the time period and the
increases that we will see in the future
but our only concern is that we don't
want municipalities who have the ability
to to use these funds
to mitigate this crisis
to not be able to to have to compete
with other municipalities in the future
because somebody's just getting a
you know their set amounts of money so
we could have potentially communities
that did not get on the ground floor of
this but who will be very capable in the
future and willing to take on programs
and use these funds
for the betterment of the state so i
just wanted to to add that we don't want
our communities to have to compete
against each other for the betterment of
all the citizens so that's all i have
thank you
so are you saying that
it should be distributed to all
communities
if you don't want them to compete
i'm i'm not going to take a
position on that sir because i just saw
the amendment and i do apologize i we
just don't like to put our member you
know our member communities 234 towns in
a position where they're
competing against each other if they
have the ability and the wherewithal and
the want and desire to take on
these types of programs will everybody
be able to do that
most likely not but for the communities
who are affected and want to be able to
move forward
and use these funds and i do understand
that there's an ability to do so we just
want to make sure those resources can be
allocated in the most equitable way to
have the most far-reaching
effects in the long term
thank you
representative aaron followed by
representative
yeah thank you mr chair so i have a
question that the
13 towns municipalities that joined in
early on this litigation
to your knowledge they already had
programs in place
to deal with the opioid issue
and they were hoping that they through
this litigation they may get some
funding to help them with those programs
i i cannot speak for all of the 13
communities my understanding is that
they have
demonstrated that they know there's a
need in their community i i can't speak
to whether or not they have programs in
place but they have a need in their
community
to mitigate this crisis
so they're probably developing programs
if they don't already have them or wish
to move forward with with some type of
programming but i can't speak to each
community and what they have in place i
apologize
okay thank you
rub's gonna help me
uh
stephen
turn that on
turn on the microphone sorry
on
do you have an opinion on whether
it would be
more useful to have more funding in the
counties
to bring together the small communities
that are not really capable of putting
together either a program or a proposal
for a program
on their own without being consolidated
i do not have an opinion on that
anything else oh thank you for your
comments thank you
wow
anything
else questions or comments
we have our work to do
represent nunes we'll see this again
correct
yes
and let me remind you
senate bill
275 has been passed by the senate
and i assume it would be coming to us
if it does come to us
we'll have an opportunity to amend it
if we need to
mr chairman
i don't think it will come to us because
it doesn't mention the allocation
it'll go to health and human services or
finance well probably not finance either
i don't know where it is you may not
mention it but it's part of the law
so if you could talk to the speaker i
will talk to the speaker thank
so if that if if going the route of the
senate bill isn't an option
um then maybe
you know just listening to what i heard
again i'll just say maybe we do come up
with an amendment that gives the
counties 30
and the
town
cities stay with the 15
i don't know how people feel about that
if
that's right
the committee was going to have to make
a decision on that and that's something
we can do
now
okay
go ahead
one more please sir
um
because we know that we're going to see
this bill
uh again
i would really like to hear we've heard
from a couple of counties in one city in
the hearings that we've had so far on
this bill
um i would really like to hear from
others
how is there a way that we can send
invites out to
any of them to to come in and talk about
about the bill or talk about the
situations that they're going through
or is that just
extending this to too much
time schedule
that
from my notes here
we need to get the
committee reports if they exist
the commission reports that they exist
robson aaron
thank you mr chair
to uh representative nunes question
we've been requesting
uh municipalities to come
to our work sessions and and also to the
hearing
but they've been all busy with um
getting ready for town meeting and doing
budgets so it's been hard to get people
to come up to concord that's all i
wanted to say
and our time schedule is very short now
uh
any other
representative romney
representative murphy my friend
the one word that rang with me is
onerous onerous
the award you used was honorous
non-honors it has to be an on
non-onerous process
at the state
with this
massive commission
it makes me shiver a little bit because
i i can see
i could see battles at that commission
by
region by
special interest by whatever
and that's why i mean i'm sure they're
all well
well um
they had the heart in the right place
and all but
that's why i part of me
says
why don't we
interesting to hear that north carolina
was in north carolina allocated 60 of
their counties
because the county's a nimble more
nimble than i think this commission
would be
so that's why i'm i've been i mean i
thought about this for the last couple
of weeks
that that maybe it's better to try to
give some more money to the to the
counties
and uh
and then then
with the remainder of that money and
it's still going to be a lot of money
to really like laser
fund from the state
to points of of need um
without and then the counties will feel
more comfortable knowing that at least
they've got a reasonable allocation
to work with
and it's probably going to be more money
than they ever thought would come their
way because some of these settlements
are going to be really large
so i i i would advocate for for that and
i i think first round i think these
these
towns and cities
okay they're expecting something so okay
we'll give them the 15
but they're going to get more if we give
more to the counties as well it's going
to back it's going to backfill to them
so maybe maybe that's the solution but i
think and that's just pat's speaking
here but
i
i think we you know if even even if the
the state went up with 40 50
this they can they can laser focus where
that money should go
but we're going to guarantee
that all the communities all the
counties get a reasonable allocation
to work programs that most of them
already have they all have county jails
we know that and we know that a lot of
the the problems wind up in the county
jails and i know in rockingham we're
working on programs to work with those
those people
uh because the a lot of the those that
are addicted
wind up in general and rocky him are
going why are we doing something with
with with we
we don't want them in the jail and so
we're creating outpatient programs
to keep them out of jail but they have
to
sign up for this program where we'll be
treating their their addictions
and i mean the counties are set up for
this
um and and again and they represent all
the communities i mean all the towns
around me are too small to do any of
this and we have to look to the next
biggest entity
is the county so
so i that's my and again i haven't been
involved with this bill
but uh i think if we're going to do
something let's let's increase the the
county allocation
keep the cat towns and then deal with
the towns later on
if we want to reduce what those original
towns get because
um
and that that's those my final comments
does anybody else have a an idea
who represented melanie i don't know
since you've read the statute better
than i did at this point
on i was told by senator rosenwald
that one of the places that they would
be spending
money probably would be
on applications from non-profits that
are working in this area
and they would be besides the counties
the only place that would be going
across all the small towns that aren't
going to be able to pull themselves
together
so it'd be good to
verify whether that's in the law or
allowed in the law
can
can you check with
representative
rosenthal
i can
i can read the statute
the the four parts and see thanks
uh
one of the things
we don't want to forget
the county has the jail
it has to deal with all the all those
things and it also works with all these
non-profits
but there's something that's every
community is involved with
and that's the
their emts and
ambulances they all have that
and the first
problem
is going to involve emt and an ambulance
and all that so
um
if we give it all to the counties
there's nothing
for them we might want to
think about that if we make these
decisions
mr chair
thank you um i i just wanted to make you
aware that um i'd be happy to work on
any refinements uh and come up with
another amendment that would be amenable
to everybody thank
you it's not an easy job
mr chairman would it be appropriate to
kind of get the feel of the committee
and see through a straw poll whether
people kind of agree with something like
a 30 percent
to counties and 15 percent to the city's
slash towns
would that help we could do that
yes
but what i want
everybody to do
is go to rsa 126
83 84 85 and 86 read those there's not
an awful lot it tells exactly what the
commission is supposed to do
and
and the split up of the funds and all
that
sorry
and we make any changes it's going to
affect that
and it's good that we do because
when we get senate bill 275
it'll affect that too
because if we pass senate bill 275 as is
it's an 85-15 split
and then
then we deal with the senate
uh
do that and then we'll take us we can
take a straw poll
at our next meeting even though
we'll be dealing with something else
so your homework is
go through that those
statues
represent
thank you mr chairman my
senator was head of the emts in the
department of safety for quite a while
on
and she
i'm going to ask her
with to find out whether under the laws
that exists
on
they could send money
to
a part of the state which
is forbidden for general funds but to a
part of the state namely that agency
within the department of safety to
distribute
across
the emts in the state
on and i think if anybody else had
connections like that to try to figure
out
whether that part of this could come out
of the general money
that would then go to all of the small
towns
i think that the small towns are really
critical to this
there's a lot to think about in such a
short period of time yes
anything else
representative ames
i just wanted to say that
in response to the questions that have
been raised about the
scope of the
ability of the commission to distribute
funds
question mark to nonprofits
or to these other statewide programs i
see no restrictions
in this legislation
so i think the the authority is to fund
projects and
the word projects is used
i think that's broad and i haven't read
the uh
the rules
that are pending that are about to be
approved and perhaps the commission
picked it up in the rules but i believe
they have the authority
to um
to establish a
far-reaching system that
would certainly pick up the obvious
places to send money to
and uh i'm sure well i would expect that
nonprofits are part of that grants to
nonprofits and a contract
to
go forward with
whatever
and i'll have jennifer check
see if there's been any reports
and then if there are
distributed to the committee members and
and the rules get the rules themselves
and and the rules
i i can't hear you um
good
excellent
anything else
all right so um
you've got your homework to do on these
four bills
and we need to exact them
shortly
we have five new bills coming up
i i printed them out
because they're not available yet but do
your homework on these five bills
and
remember
when we deal with these five bills is
strictly the revenue and funds
aspect of the bills not the
policy thank you everybody get everybody
signed in
the wheel doesn't go over it
it catches on
is
appreciate you
sure
uh
on
tuesday or wednesday before the session
fairly effortlessly
um
yeah wrapping that up in two
hours don't remember seeing anything
from the speaker
yeah that was just yesterday
i'm worried
i am not a person
you